There is a three or four minute clip of an
interview that Donald Trump granted to Jonathan
Swan and Axios reporter.
And it is the stuff of legend.
It is the stuff of horror.
It is the stuff of nightmares.
Donald Trump saying during this interview
that not only does he read a lot, but he comprehends
what he reads, what he reads really, really
well, better than anyone that Jonathan Swan
has ever interviewed, or at least recently,
which is quite a statement.
Take a look at this.
I wouldn't mind if it reached my desk.
I would have done something about it.
It never reached my desk because to read your
recent brief.
I do.
I read a lot.
You know, I read a lot.
They like to say.
I read.
I read a lot.
You're written.
He had extraordinarily well probably better
than anybody that you've interviewed in a
long time.
I read a lot.
I spend a lot of time with at meetings.
So is there anybody in my audience who's willing
to defend Trump on this?
That his reading comprehension is really,
really good by most reports.
Donald Trump has not read a single entire
book in decades in his entire adult life,
which is like the last 50 years.
I am not aware of any book that Donald Trump
has actually read cover to cover people I
know who have really good reading comprehension
skills.
They never brag about reading comprehension.
Put quite simply, like anybody who has good
reading comprehension skills talks about the
math.
The subject matter of what they read rather
than the fact that they're really good at
reading and understanding stuff.
And this was only the tip of the iceberg.
A bunch of other strange moments in this interview
and the story really in the interview, other
than Trump claiming he can read well, which
is a strange thing for presidents to ever
have to defend.
The real theme of this interview is Trump
bending over backwards to defend, not confronting
Vladimir Putin about anything.
Take a look at Trump here explaining why he
did nothing about that entire Russia Russian
bounty story, which I continue trying to bring
up.
I did nothing about Russia arming the Taliban,
did nothing about anything related to Russia.
Take a look.
I have so many briefings on so many different
countries, but this one didn't reach my desk.
The reason I say this is, is even if you don't
believe the intel, this particular piece of
intelligence and there is dispute, no doubt
there is disputing intel she made about it.
Your former John Nicholson, former head of
forces in Afghanistan, said this when he was
working for you, that Russia is supplying
weapons to the Taliban.
Isn't that enough to challenge Putin over
the killings?
Well, we sold those weapons when they were
fighting Russia to, you know, when we were
when they were fighting with the Taliban when
Afghanistan's a different era.
Well.
I'm just saying.
So Trump just radically brings up a completely
different situation unrelated to him as president
and Putin now as president and their relationship.
This, by the way, doesn't have to be anything
more than Trump is enamored with Putin.
You know, you have now there's this slice
of the left who's getting a lot of mileage
of saying, oh, the Russia gaiters, the Russia
Gaiters.
They were crazy.
All, you know, you don't you don't have to
be alleging anything here other than Trump,
we know, is really impressed with authoritarians.
The people he's impressed with our Putin do
today, Kim Jong un, Aradale one, et cetera.
And there's no conspiracy being alleged.
Other than Trump's enamored with dictators.
And he seems particularly enamored with Vladimir
Putin.
And he seems to be finding any way he can
grasping at straws to defend not being tough
on Putin, not confronting Putin.
That's all that this has to be.
You don't have to allege some bigger conspiracy.
Now, later in the interview, Jonathan Swan
pushes Trump an insanely sort of ends up having
to explain to Trump what's going on.
It's very bad and it exposes Trump's complete
lack of knowledge of even basic foreign foreign
policy realities.
You surely heard that, right?
I mean, it's well known in the US that they
are arming the Taliban in Russia.
I don't know when you say arming, is the Taliban
paying or they do Russia ossified weapons
and money to the Taliban.
I have heard that.
But it's never right again.
It's never reached my desk.
And he said on the record when he was in Russia,
doesn't want anything to do with Afghanistan.
Let me just hear about Russia.
Trump has access to the not that he necessarily
is taking people up on it, but Trump has access
to the latest and greatest intelligence in
the world.
And you can tell that he seems to be hearing
much of what Jonathan Swan is bringing up
for the first time from a reporter or at least
hearing it in a way that he has to react substantively.
Then Trump, knowing that he's flailing and
failing, tries to give Jonathan Swan a history
lesson.
And it gets really awkward.
Russia used to be a thing called the Soviet
Union because.
Afghanistan.
They went bankrupt.
They became Russia, just so you do understand,
OK?
The last thing that Russia wants to do is
get too much involved with Afghanistan.
They tried that once.
It didn't work out.
How wild is that?
Right.
But but to focus on the primary topic here.
Donald Trump has not confronted Vladimir Putin
about supposed Russian bounties for Taliban
killing U.S. troops.
Trump hasn't talked to him about it.
And Trump clearly has no interest in talking
to Vladimir Putin about it, despite the fact
that they've now had at least one conversation
since that story came out.
It's a sort of jaw dropping lack of self reflection
or even an interest in understanding what
the circumstances are and just how bad it
looks.
And it's hard to fathom that this is the president
of the United States, at least for a few more
months, and hopefully no longer sort of like
a sixth grader.
Listen, I remember there were times, maybe
not in sixth grade, but in middle school where
I wrote a book report about a book I didn't
read, OK?
I admitted there were times when I did that.
That's sort of the equivalent of what Donald
Trump is trying to do here.
Now, the very last thing Donald Trump says
it never reached his desk, that this story
of of alleged Russian bounty's never reached
his desk.
That definitely seems to be a lie.
There has been widespread and specific New
York Times and other reporting which claims
that indeed Donald Trump was briefed multiple
times about this and he just did nothing.
Now, I've given you the timeline in the past,
arguably as many as three or four different
times over the last year and a half or so
where Donald Trump was briefed about this.
New York Times reported that Trump got written
briefing in February of 20/20.
And that's just, you know, five, six months
ago in a presidential daily briefing.
Trump in this interview claims he reads it.
So a sort of clever question, because Jonathan
Swan gets Trump to at least claim he reads
his PDB, as we know that this was in his PDB
in February.
Now, CNN says that Trump was briefed somewhere
in the area of March, April, May on this.
And then Associated Press sources quote, top
White House officials who say Trump was made
aware of this in early 2019, a full year earlier
than The New York Times and CNN say.
So it's it's not just lies.
It's not just being enamored with Putin.
It's also either incompetence or a complete
lack of memory about the fact that he was
allegedly briefed about this multiple times
or a sort of all of the above scenario.
But there's no I mean, it's you know, either
you care about this stuff or you don't.
Either you're concerned about having an incompetent
buffoon as president or you're not.
Tens of millions of people are not.
And they're going to be voting for another
four years of this in just a few months.
So if we want to prevent that from being the
outcome, we know what to do.
There's no I don't have to give you any.
You don't have to understand mechanical physics
or string theory or anything to understand
what the thing is.
You've got
to vote.
Everybody's got
That's it.